[Música]
cassano se recupera de la escalada
bélica de 11 días que comenzó el 10 de
mayo 2021 en su primer aniversario es
decir hoy se cumple en plena tensión
entre distraer el grupo islamista hamás
por ahora no se ha desencadenado una
ofensiva con el enclave pero la
posibilidad de otro conflicto abierto
entre el ejército israelí y los grupos
armados de casas sigue sobre la mesa
desde que comenzó hace más de un mes
otro repunte de violencia en esa región
ataques cometidos por árabes israelíes y
palestinos en el último mes y medio se
han saldado con 18 israelíes y al menos
30 palestinos muertos el epicentro de
los más recientes enfrentamientos fue la
mezquita de al-aqsa durante las
celebraciones del ramadán que
coincidieron este año con la pesa para
ello entonces quiero saludar en este
momento a nuestros a nuestro primer
invitado el día 6 haya el ex director
del núcleo de estudios de medio oriente
de la universidad austral de argentina
gracias a iu por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 en su
opinión a qué se debe entonces este
nuevo recrudecimiento de la violencia
pero lo que hemos visto en las últimas
dos o tres semanas en torno a la
finalización del ramadán ha sido un
nuevo digamos una nueva incursión de las
fuerzas de seguridad israelíes en la
mezquita de al-aqsa muy similar al
evento que tuvo lugar el año pasado
estas fuerzas de seguridad que llegan al
alza tienen un
motivo para estar ahí y es servir de
separación entre los grupos de
ultraderecha que van a hacer
manifestaciones y quienes de pronto
visitar el entorno de la mezquita y las
personas que estaban festejando ahí el
final del ramadán los musulmanes que
estaban digamos participando de las
ceremonias religiosas en uno de los
templos más sagrados del islam pero
claro en ese contexto la intervención
israelí favorable a estos grupos de
ultraderecha y hasta último punto para
evitar el enfrentamiento entre ambos
entramos grupos ha derivado en una serie
de excesos bueno que hemos visto no
golpear mujeres y ancianos etcétera no
claro se ha pasado ya un año como lo
como estábamos diciendo la introducción
de nuestro tema de este conflicto de los
11 días el año pasado cuál es su balance
digamos cómo se ha ido preparando el
terreno para este nuevo repunte y si
podemos ver ojalá no un nuevo
recrudecimiento digamos como lo vimos
hacer hace un año bien entonces aunque
este escenario es muy similar no de
pronto parece que ya lo vimos el año
pasado hay algunas diferencias que
permiten esperar no puede hacer
futurología sí pero permiten esperar no
de una manera que jamás
ejercite un cierto autocontrol y esto es
el rol creciente que ha estado jugando
egipto en los últimos meses y ha parado
en la política de bay en egipto ha
ayudado a
hamas que está gobernando gaza a
alcanzar una serie de créditos a su
persona creo que 500 millones de dólares
para la reconstrucción de ds ds de ese
enclave y en ese contexto gas a
esto jamás trata de mostrarse moderado
o trata de alguna manera de moderarse
frente a otros grupos que también
participan en la franja de gaza no y
tiene un discurso mucho más encendido el
fondo de la burocracia de hamás lo que
trata es de mostrarse como un buen
administrador
frente a este broker que tiene con eeuu
y también con él con israel parece ser
este creciente rol de egipto que le va a
dar mucha habilidad mucha visibilidad
internacional y mucho peso regional si
logra generar un acuerdo entre fatah y
hamás es lo que me parece a mí está
decidiendo de alguna manera a hamás de
alentar una incursión mucho más
importante es decir en la retórica lo
vemos a esto jamás está pronunciando y
está alentando a que defiendan la ciudad
santa de jerusalén a los palestinos pero
en sus actitudes concretas sobre
políticas vemos que están ejerciendo de
alguna manera el autocontrol un
escenario diferente vemos del lado
israelí yo lo veo a bennett un poco
perdido no tratando de alguna manera de
evitar que la facción
árabe salga de su coalición como
amenazado que va a ser el próximo
viernes y también tratando de evitar que
los diputados de kadima
salgan también de su de su coalición lo
que dejaría definitivamente al gobierno
en minoría entonces claro tenemos a un
pene que un día trata de digamos ejercer
control sobre los grupos de otra derecha
y al otro día anuncia cuatro mil nuevos
en nuevas viviendas en los asentamientos
no y la prohibición de que nadie visite
al aqsa haciendo una violación a los
acuerdos de soberanía que mantiene con
los palestinos
claro esa y entonces le quiero preguntar
en todo este contexto que estamos viendo
y ya lo que se está digamos
cocinando no en esa en esa región en
términos que puede ser pues una olla de
presión digamos en cualquier momento
lamentablemente el conflicto nuevamente
puede estallar como como lo hemos visto
en este conflicto de larga data se puede
algún día solucionar estos pueblos
estaban condenados entonces a vivir
siempre en un conflicto
digamos por el fin de los tiempos
excelente pregunta cuando mis alumnos me
dicen esto en el salón de clase profesor
y esto cómo se resuelve bueno yo les
digo miren en el 78 tuvimos la foto el
68 tuvimos la foto del acuerdo de paz
entre egipto e israel en el año 93
tuvimos la foto entre israel y palestina
no ahí recordamos hay conflicto en el
medio estrechando la mano tenemos que
creer que esa foto es posible en alguna
circunstancia como lo fueron el 78 como
lo fue en el 73 quizás para se tengan
que pasar tengo que pasar más tiempo
hasta que esperar aquí la coyuntura
internacional favorable como lo fue en
ese momento
las cosas no se cocinaron ya para el
otro pero lo que no hay que perder es la
esperanza a que un arreglo es posible un
arreglo en el largo plazo pero es
posible no fuimos testigos del acuerdo
del 78 el 93 tiene que ser posible
generar un nuevo acuerdo que destrabe
esta situación y bueno garantice a unos
que puedan vivir en paz ya los otros que
puedan habitar un territorio plenamente
soberano